Okay folks, quick reminder. Your
third quiz is a week from today. And it
feels like just last week, like you took
your last quiz. But because the break
was so late this year, there was almost
nothing I could do because by the time I
didn't want to give it the week you came
back from break, obviously. So,
the third quiz will cover capital
structure, which is pretty much what we
will do through the much of it we've
already done, but we'll finish off this
week.
And then, of course, 2 weeks after that
is the last day of class, and then
finals. So, you know, lots coming up,
and I'll keep reminding you, don't
worry. Lots of nagging coming up. Um
So, today we're going to continue our
discussion and finish up this financing
mix question. If you remember, we were
talking about finding the right mix of
debt and equity for your company.
You can use the cost of capital
approach, you can use the APV approach,
you can look at your peer group. But we
started with this presumption of what if
your company's debt ratio is different
from the optimal?
And we looked at the easier half, right?
When you're under-levered, what can you
do? And the key question there was, do I
do we need to do something quickly?
If you're under threat of takeover, you
don't have the luxury of time. You got
to go out and increase leverage quickly.
Do a debt for equity swap, buy back
stock with borrowed money, but
increasing your debt ratio quickly. But
if you can,
it's probably better to spread this out.
Take your time doing it because that
way, if you misestimated your optimal,
you can fix it as you go along.
And then, the follow-up question I asked
was, do you have good projects? The
reason that matters, if you have good
projects and you have debt capacity, you
have a marriage made in heaven. You can
use the debt capacity to get to your
optimal, and then get the net present
values of the good projects to add on
top of that.
It's always better to borrow money and
take great projects than it is to borrow
money and buy back stock.
And if you do borrow money, if you don't
have good projects, then of course, you
have to decide what to do over time. And
there's one final question.
The two choice two ways in which you can
return cash to your shareholders. One is
to pay dividends,
and the other is to buy back stock.
Which one's better?
Depends on your shareholders. I mean,
think like a shareholder.
Now, dividends versus buybacks, and this
is something we'll come back to. The key
question is, you know, do I want the
cash now and have to pay taxes right
now, in which case you're saying, I'll
get the dividends. Older investors,
poorer investors tend to prefer
dividends.
But there's a whole set of investors
that don't pay me dividends. I don't
want to pay tax. I'd prefer to get the
price appreciation.
Whichever group of shareholders are the
shareholders in your company, we'll talk
about this called a dividend clientele,
is going to drive what you pay.
So, that's if you're under-levered.
And if you're going to have a promise, I
said, hope and pray that you have too
little debt.
Cuz here's the other side of the
equation, and here things get
unpleasant.
What if you have too much debt?
Your actual debt ratio is 60%, you need
to be at 30%. You're saying, just
reverse everything, right? You just need
to bring your debt ratio. Let's go
through each of the things you're going
to try to do and why it's going to be
difficult for you to do it.
You're the CEO of a company, Weight
Watchers.
Significant trouble now. Why?
Couple of reasons. The name itself is a
problem now, right? It's a you know,
Weight Watchers at one point in time was
you know, now people, you know, when you
put in that as your as the name of the
company, you already are going to have
issues with uh you picking on people are
overweight. So, but that was from a
different But Ozempic we'll go over here
basically killed their business model.
The company is in trouble. So, as I go
through the choices, think about whether
any of these is going to work for Weight
Watchers.
The first question I'm going to ask is,
is the company under threat of
bankruptcy? What do you look at to make
that judgment?
The case of Weight Watchers.
What are the things that give give away
the fact they're in trouble?
One is the rating, right? If you look at
the ratings, they're now down to I think
C double I mean, they're well below
investment grade. They've dropped to a
point where the ratings agencies have
put them in what's saying, any day now.
I did this morning, I was looking at
news story. Every single news story I
read in the last 6 months about Weight
Watchers is about how death is imminent.
When you're under bankruptcy threat,
there's no need for serious research.
You will know. If you work at that
company, you will know. Your paychecks
might bounce.
And every aspect of the company is going
to be depressing because you're on a
pathway to doom.
So, let's look at some of the things you
could try to do, and let's see if these
will work for Weight Watchers. One is to
you can go to your lenders and offer
them equity in your company
to replace the debt.
Think like a lender. I come to you and
say, "Look, would you like equity in my
in my company?" What's your first
reaction? No, thank you.
You can ask your lenders you could try
to sell assets.
The case of Weight Watchers, what assets
do they have?
Maybe they lists of
uh because they do have a list of people
who are loyal to the Weight Watchers.
Maybe they can sell that list. But if
everybody knows you need the cash right
away, your bargaining power is shot to
hell. So, when you try to sell things,
you're not going to get full value. You
might get half of value, a quarter of
value. So, you can try, but it's going
to be difficult.
What if you try to renegotiate with
their lenders?
Take the 3-year loan into a 30-year
loan.
Make a 12% interest rate into 1.2%
interest rate. What's your reaction as a
lender?
I'm not doing it. But you know what I
threaten you with?
What happens if I decide to actually
declare bankruptcy?
I end up in the courts, and the lawyers
are going to take it anyway. So, would
you take these terms or wait 30 years to
get your money after all this process
works through?
It's ironic, but your bargaining power
as a borrower is greatest before you
actually declare bankruptcy.
So, you go to the lenders and say, "Hey,
do you want me to declare It's like
negotiating with somebody who owes money
to you and has a gun to his or her head
saying, you either agree to my terms or
I'll blow my brains out." Right? You're
not going to get any of your money.
Essentially, you're negotiating saying,
"Look, if you don't agree to my terms,
effectively, I'm going to go end up in
the court system, you're not going to
see your money."
Let me give you an example of how
effective this strategy is.
In the 1800s, Peru had a debt problem,
which is not new. It's Latin America,
every country goes through a debt
problem. Peru had a debt problem.
So, it was the French bank that had owed
that had lent them money. So, the time
for the debt payment came came due, and
Peru didn't have the money.
So, they sent out I don't know how you
sent out messages then. So, by carrier
pigeon, I guess, or by ship,
saying, "We don't have the money,
but we can pay with guano."
You know what guano is?
It's bird droppings, right?
Bird droppings actually what fertilizer
is supposed to be really good. So, we
don't And the French bank initially bank
initially said, "No, no, we don't take
guano. We need cash." And Peru said,
"It's guano or nothing."
And the French bank said, "We'll take
the guano." All right.
Basically, you know that if you tip this
company over the edge and you end up in
bankruptcy court, you might see less
than you get in these
And that's why these renegotiations with
companies that are on the verge of
bankruptcy or even in bankruptcy become
so intense because the lenders try to
get something to keep the company going.
But it's not a good place to be.
But could you be over-levered and not in
the bankruptcy threat? Absolutely. You
can still be a healthy company, but know
that you have more debt than you should,
in which case you have the luxury of
time. And here again, I'm going to ask
you the same question I asked you
when you had excess debt capacity. Do
you have good projects? Because if you
do,
here's what I think you should do. You
should take all of your earnings every
year. Stop paying dividends, right? If
you're If you're over-levered, the last
thing you want to do is make your equity
lower. So, stop paying stop buying back
stock. Take every dollar of earnings and
pump it back into those good projects.
And over time, here's what will happen.
Your equity will rise in value. It's not
even that your debt goes down. You
essentially grow out of the problem.
It's the nicest way to get rid of a debt
problem. It's essentially increase the
value of your firm to the point where
your debt problem goes away.
So, if you have the luxury of time and
you have good projects, go take the good
projects with equity.
This case, retained earnings. And over
time, your debt ratio will decrease.
Your debt problem will go away. But, if
you don't have good projects, again,
you're back on the treadmill of having
to pay down debt over time.
And you try your best. You take your
retained earnings. You pay down your
debt. And over time, you hope to get
back to health. And you hope there's no
macro crisis that happens. A tariff war
will essentially tip you over, something
you did not anticipate.
But, there are a lot of companies right
now that are waiting to see. They
thought they were on the pathway to
bring their debt down. They're looking
now to see, maybe we won't be able to
make it.
That's the framework. I'm going to try
to apply it to Disney, but I'd like you
to think about applying this for your
companies when you get to the point of
having an optimal debt ratio.
So, Disney in November of 2013, their
actual debt ratio was 12%. The optimal
is 40%. They were under-levered.
Are they under takeover threat? At least
in 2013, I thought not. And I'll give
you my reasons why. One, it's a pretty
large company, 130 billion.
Second,
there's no insider holding, so that
works against it. So, that But, there's
a third factor, which if you remember
the Jensen's alpha that I computed for
Disney.
Does anybody remember?
It was 9.02% a year for the 5 years
leading to 2013. You're negotiating from
a position of strength if you're Disney.
So, essentially, I assume that they
would not be targeted because of those
factors. It's a subjective judgment, and
each of you will have to do this with
your company, right?
Do they have good projects? Again, if
you remember when we looked at the
return on capital Disney, it was 12.61%
above their cost of capital. They were
earning excess returns. Will they
continue to? I am assuming they can. So,
in the case of Disney, given that they
have plans to expand their theme parks,
build new ones,
build up their movie businesses. At that
point in time, streaming was not an
issue. We said, take projects with debt.
But, I'm going to keep an eye on those
projects. If those projects start
tipping over and become negative net
present value, I want my cash back.
This was at the heart of the activist
targeting of Disney last year.
Disney was borrowing money, but what was
it investing in? The money in?
What was the business that all the money
went into?
Disney Plus. And what was Disney Plus
doing? It was draining cash like crazy.
So, I did Before Iger came back, when
Bob Chapek was doing it, activists said,
"Hey, this can't go on. You're going to
suck the company dry." And essentially,
you saw the fight over that. And Disney
conceded. In In a sense, they become a
little more restrained in how much money
they spend on Disney streaming.
So, that was my Disney framework. And
you as you work through your company,
make the best judgments you can. There's
no No checkbox you can say, "No, I know
for sure." But, make your judgments to
decide. And some of your companies will
be over-levered. You have to figure out,
are they in the bankruptcy threat? If
they have a rating, you can look at the
rating.
But, more simply, look at their interest
expenses. Look at their earnings. Say,
will they get into trouble if they get a
shock? And if they do, if if they are on
the verge of trouble, you have to do
something quickly.
So,
when you look at your firm, here are the
choices you'll face. No, maybe there's
no change in leverage needed. That could
happen for some of your firms. In some,
you might need an immediate change,
either because they're in the bankruptcy
threat when they're over-levered, or
because they could be taken over. Or,
they can have a gradual change. And if
they decide to change their debt, there
are two pathways they can go. One is
stay entirely on the liability side of
the balance sheet, where you either
increase debt or increase equity. The
other is to try to take projects with
that additional debt or additional
equity. So, those are the two choices
you'll face.
So, to complete this process, I'm going
to list out some of the ways in which a
company can increase its debt ratio
decrease its debt ratio quickly.
And some of the ways it can increase or
decrease its debt ratio gradually. I've
kind of listed them already, but might
as well pull them all together.
So, if you have If you want to increase
your debt ratio, if you want to stay
entirely on the liability side, you can
borrow money and either buy back stock
or pay a special dividend. What does it
help? Borrowing money increases your
debt right away. Buying back
You can make your debt ratio go from 0
to 40% in no time at all.
If you want to decrease your debt rate
Or if you want to Let's say with the
increased the debt ratio. You can also
take your assets, sell them off, use the
cash
to buy back stock. What does that do? It
reduces equity. If you already have
debt, your debt ratio will will
increase. So, if you're a company with
debt already existing, you can sell off
assets, buy back stock, divest a
division,
do a buyback, and that will increase
your debt ratio.
If you want to decrease your debt ratio
quickly,
again, you can stay on the liability
side. Try to issue new equity and use it
to retire debt. That will increase your
equity, reduce your debt,
increase your equity you know, the
proportion of your capital that comes
from equity essentially overnight. Or,
if you want to do it with a by selling
assets, you can sell the assets, use
them to pay down debt.
So, depending on which problem you have,
under-levered or over-levered, you have
levers under your control.
Now, if you want to increase your debt
ratio, decrease it gradually,
if you If you look over time, if you
want to increase your debt ratio, you'd
either have to use dividends or
buybacks. Either reduces equity. So,
whatever you're doing, you're
essentially looking at that balance
between debt and equity. The one thing
about changing debt ratios gradually
over time
is you're targeting a firm value that
will actually shift over time. And
here's the reason. Let's say a company's
worth a billion dollars today in market
cap terms. If it's fairly valued, it
should be worth 1.8 billion next year,
1.15 billion the year after.
Looks like I'm making up stuff, right?
I No, so but why would the value of your
firm change over time? And And what will
it change by if it's fairly valued?
What's the cost of equity?
It's what the equity should earn for you
as an investor. If a stock is fairly
valued, its equity should always should
increase by the cost of equity year
after year.
So, what that means, a 40% debt ratio in
5 years will be a much, much higher
amount of debt than a 40% debt ratio
today.
Right? Because you're targeting a bigger
firm.
So, tougher to do, but But again, it's
just details. The mechanics of doing it
are pretty straightforward.
So, that's the financing mix part. Any
questions at all about the financing
mix? So, be open to the possibility that
your company's optimal debt ratio can be
0%. It might not be because you've done
something wrong. It just might be that
your company really can't afford to get
even to a 10% debt ratio. It doesn't
have the earnings.
And leave open the possibility that at
least for some companies, your optimal
debt ratio can be 70, 80, or once in a
while, you might get a 90% debt ratio
for a company. Very And those are the
kinds of companies you targeted if
you're If you're a leveraged buyout, you
know, practitioner, those are the kinds
of companies that can carry immense
amounts of debt.
So, now let's look at the second half of
the financing principle. If you
remember, I said the objective when you
go out and borrow money is to match your
debt up to your assets.
So, I want to start by explaining why
that helps you as a company. Where does
it show up?
And then talk about the mechanics of
designing debt from scratch.
So, let's start by looking at a company
with a firm value goes up and down for
lots of different reasons. It's a
cyclical company, the value goes up some
years, goes down. If this company goes
out and borrows debt that remains
constant in value over time,
it's going to be in trouble. Every time
the firm value drops below the value of
the debt, technically, this company is
bankrupt.
It might not be forced into bankruptcy,
but its equity is worth nothing.
Let's say I take the same company, and I
redesign the debt so that it increases
and decreases with the value of the
firm. In other words, when the value of
the firm goes up, the value of the debt
goes up. When the value of the firm goes
down, the value of the debt goes down.
It's a very strange kind of debt, but
we'll talk about how we can try to do
it. This company never goes bankrupt,
even though it has 30% more debt than
the previous company.
The reason we want to match match debt
up to the assets reduces default risk.
And by reducing default risk, it reduces
your cost of debt and your cost of
capital. It allows you to borrow more
money.
So, what we're try going to try to do is
take a company, and as I go through this
process, I want you to start thinking
about your company.
And think about how you'd go through
this process of designing that.
So, first step in the process. So, let
let's suppose you are the company and I
am the person trying to design that for
you.
I'm going to have a series of questions,
and as I list the questions, let's think
about why they matter.
First question I'm going to ask you is
typically how long-term are your
projects?
Let's take a few examples. Take Boeing.
What does a typical project's duration
look like?
Probably takes 10, 15, 20 years of R&D,
and then if it the R&D looks like it's
going to work, you build an assembly
plant that might take another 5 years.
And then you use that assembly plant to
make aircraft for the next 30 years. The
last Boeing 747 rolled off the assembly
lines 40 years after the first one. From
start to finish, that was a
50-to-60-year project.
So, what kind of debt should Boeing
take?
Really long-term debt.
Boeing was one of two companies that
issued 100-year bonds. This is a long
time ago,
15 years ago, 100-year bonds, 100-year
corporate bonds.
The other company was Disney.
We'll talk about why Disney might issue
100-year bonds, but you can see why.
In contrast, let's take Oracle.
What does a typical project look like
for Oracle?
Definitely not 60 years, probably 8, 10
years, maybe even 6 or 7 years.
Technology companies, because the
technology shifts so
So, if you're looking at a technology
company, I wouldn't expect to see
100-year debt
on your balance sheet, because your
typical assets are much more short-term.
Take a third example. Let's take
Coca-Cola.
What's its biggest asset?
I'm sorry, what?
Do you think the taste actually matters?
Coca-Cola thought it did, right?
Remember in 1986, they tried to fix the
taste with new Coke, old Coke, and they
realized nobody cared, and in fact the
taste was not the issue. That if you put
crap in a red can and put Coca-Cola on
it,
the the mind would take over, and you'd
drink it and say, "That tastes
incredibly good. It's a Coca-Cola." It's
brand name, right?
I mean, let's face it, every soda, if
you if you if you really did a blindfold
test, even if I said, "No Coca-Cola, and
I drink it," I could give you three
different Coca-Colas from the three
three different parts of the world.
I I'd always drink the Mexican Coca-Cola
when I'm in San Diego, because I like
the sugar in my Coca-Cola. Tastes very
different from traditional Coca-Cola.
It's brand name.
Is brand name a really long-term asset
or a short-term asset?
It's perhaps the longest-term asset
known
in business, right?
Look at how long Coca-Cola's brand name
has lasted. Because it's mysterious.
Nobody knows where it comes from. Nobody
knows how sometimes why it goes away. If
your biggest asset brand name, anything
about borrowing money to build up that
brand name, you should probably take
long-term debt. So, I want you to think
out of the box when you think about what
does a typical project look like.
You're saying, "What about a bottling
plant? Why doesn't that work for
Coca-Cola to use the bottling plants?"
Cuz they don't actually own the bottling
plants anymore. They've spun off the
bottlers. They're purely the syrup and
the brand name. That's all the company
is.
So, the first question I'm going to ask
you is about the duration of your
projects.
Second stop I'm going to ask you what
currency are your cash flows in?
So, let's stay with Coca-Cola.
What currency are the cash flows going
to be in?
70 different currencies.
As best as I can, I wanted to design
debt that reflects your currency mix.
Again, because I want to match debt up
to your assets.
It's easier to do with Coca-Cola than
with Boeing, because with Boeing the
currency mix keeps shifting, because
every time they sign a new aircraft
contract, it depends on which airline
they sell it to.
You know?
So, if it's to Qatar Air, you're going
to get it in a very different currency
than if you sell to Singapore Air. So,
much more difficult to do, because the
currency mix gets staggered. But, best
as you can, you want to try to match
your debt up in terms of currencies.
The third question I'm going to ask you
is going to sound strange, but you'll
see why it matters.
I'm going to ask you how your cash flows
respond to inflation, or how you as a
business respond to inflation.
So, let's say as a business, when you
have inflation,
what's the first effect you have? Your
costs all start to go up, right?
And as a company, what did you like to
do? You'd like to pass those costs on to
your customers to survive.
The question I'm asking you is how much
pricing power do you have?
If you have lots of pricing power, are
you going to be able to pass inflation
through to your customers? You're
saying, "Why do I care?"
Remember the choice between fixed-rate
and floating-rate debt?
Derek explained to me how floating-rate
debt works.
And and the driver for interest rates is
inflation, right? So, if inflation in 2
years is going to be 8%, the
interest rates are going to go up, and
if you have floating-rate debt, your
expenses are going to go up. You're
saying, "Oh my god, what am I going to
do?" If you have pricing power, you just
pass it through.
You see where this is going to lead me,
right? If I have pricing power, I'm a
much better candidate for floating-rate
debt
than if I don't have pricing power. If
you're an airline, for God's sake, don't
issue floating-rate debt. You don't have
pricing power, and if you don't have
pricing power and interest rates go up,
you're going to get squeezed and perhaps
go bankrupt.
The fourth question I'm going to ask you
are you a growth company? Are you a
mature company? I'm asking about, you
know, are you
Walmart or Costco, in which case much of
your high growth is behind you? Are you
Celsius, where a lot of high growth is
ahead of you?
Why does that matter? That's going to
drive the choice between straight debt
and convertible debt.
Convertible debt is debt with an equity
option added on. By itself, it's neither
better nor worse, but one of the
advantages of issuing convertible debt
is your coupon rate will be low, because
you it's because you gave away that
equity option. And if you're a growth
company, that's exactly what you want.
You want the coupon expenses to be low
now, because you can you can't afford to
make big interest payments. And over
time, they might get converted to
straight debt, but if things go well,
you should be able to make those debt
payments later.
So, if you're a high-growth company,
much better candidate for convertible
debt. If you're a low-growth company, go
with straight debt. Why give away
options?
And there's a final question I'm going
to ask you, which is completely
company-specific. Tell me what else
affects your cash flows, and I'm going
to try to bring it into the debt. Let's
not be mysterious. Let me give you an
example. Let's suppose you're Barrick
Gold, gold mining company. What's the
biggest single factor driving your
earnings?
It's gold prices, right? Gold prices go
up, your earnings go up.
Gold prices go down, your earnings go
down.
Is there a way I could design debt
that lets a gold mining company borrow
money and not have to go bankrupt if all
gold prices collapse? What would I have
to do? Wait.
Tie the coupon rate to the price of
gold, right?
The very first These This is This is a
group of bonds called commodity-linked
bonds. And the very first
commodity-linked bonds were gold-linked
bonds in the early 1980s.
Gold prices go up, your coupon rate can
be 12%. Gold prices collapse, the coupon
rate can go to 2%.
Now, of course, that's expanded out. In
fact, one of the things that's always
puzzled me is why smaller oil companies
don't all issue oil-linked bonds.
Because every one of them, when oil
prices drop, I mean, last week there was
talk about shale oil companies going
bankrupt, because the oil price had gone
to $57 a barrel.
If you tied the coupon rate, you're not
giving away anything, right? It's built
into the price. So, essentially, you're
doing it is to match up your debt to
your assets.
It is true that you can issue regular
bonds and then use derivatives to try to
manage that risk, right? But, that's
asking for trouble. Why not build it
into the bond in the first place, so you
don't have to go out and use options and
futures to manage that divergence?
So, the first stop is to make sure
you're designing debt that matches the
business.
In the real world, how do businesses
pick what debt to issue?
They call in an investment banker, and
they say, "Tell me what debt's right for
me." This is like going into an
electronic store and asking the guy,
say, "Can you tell me what the right TV
for me is?"
I'll predict what you're going to come
back with.
That OLED Samsung $3,000 80-in TV that
won't even fit in your apartment.
But, it's, you know, he's doing what's
right for him.
If you ask bankers what the right debt
for you is, they don't know your
business like you do. The people who are
best positioned to determine what the
right debt for them are the people
running the business.
And this isn't rocket science. You're
saying, "What are the things I worry
about, and I can I bring them into the
debt?"
So, that's the first stop is to make
sure your debt and your and your assets
are matched up. Any questions? Yes.
Boeing. Yeah.
It's like a predictable big R&D phase. I
don't think of it as like
a construction loan, where they do like
a construction.
Right.
If it's a single If this is your first
aircraft, and you only one aircraft
working through, it's going to be messy,
right? Because in that initial period,
when you're all negative cash flows, the
lender is lending based on expectations
of future cash flows.
And that's projects project financing.
So, you have to line up things in there
to protect you. The advantage when you
have a company like Boeing is you have a
portfolio of projects at different
stages. As the 747 rolled in, the 707
was still throwing off lots of cash
flow. So, what the lender is lending
against is the portfolio of
infrastructure projects.
And that way the cash flows. So, that's
why it's so much more difficult
designing debt for a company starting
off with a single project. Gets easier.
Biotech companies can't borrow money.
Why? It's a single project working its
way through the pipeline. All negative
cash flows, but nobody's going to lend
you money in those early phases because
they've no idea what's going to show up.
But as you get a portfolio projects, you
borrow against a portfolio.
So, second stop, make sure you haven't
been too clever for your own good. Let
me explain. What we what were we doing
with the debt on the previous page? We
were trying to make debt look like
equity. Right? That's basically what
we're trying. In fact, you might have
been so good at designing debt that
looks like equity.
That the IRS looks at and say, "You know
what? That's equity." In which case the
entire point of issuing debt goes away.
So, make sure that whatever you've
designed to look like equity actually
pass the debt test.
Who are you going to visit?
The tax lawyers. Right?
They've got to read through the tax law
and make sure this passes it. And in
that process, you might massage the debt
to maximize your tax benefits. I'll give
you an example when you issue zero
coupon debt.
If you look at the interest, it's zero
every year. Right? But the way the IRS
actually allows you to claim tax
benefits is on an imputed interest
expense.
That's something you need to know when
you go out and decide what kind of debt
to issue. So, make sure the debt is
deductible. And if you have If you're a
multinational, this is the point at
which you decide that your debt is going
to be in Germany rather than Ireland
because you get a 29% tax benefit.
So, design the perfect debt. Make sure
you get the tax advantages.
Third stop,
it's a trick you got to pull off that I
don't even know how companies managed
to, but they try all the time.
There are three very different groups of
interest in here. You got to try to keep
them all happy. So, let's play this out.
You're a Midwestern company.
You're the CFO.
You want to issue a security next week.
And you're going to visit New York to
make sure the security is well received.
So, your first stop
is at Moody's, the ratings agency.
So, let me ask you a question.
What do rating agencies care about?
What's the one thing they're focused on?
Default risk. Default risk. Default
risk. Right? So, what do they want you
to issue next week to reduce default
risk? Debt or equity?
They want you to issue equity. So, you
tell them in the morning, "Hey, I'm
issuing equity." You're saying, "What's
the big deal?"
In the afternoon, you visit visit the
equity research associates who track
your company.
Do they like it when you issue equity?
In fact, when you issue equity, what
happens to your share count?
It goes up. And then the dilution
bogeyman comes out of the closet.
So, you got to convince these equity
research analysts that the same security
that you convinced the ratings agency
was equity this morning has now
magically become debt.
But we're not done. If you're a
regulated company, there's a third stop
to make.
Insurance company bank.
What do they need? All their regulatory
capital ratios are built around equity.
So, they wanted to So, the security goes
back to being So, it starts the morning
as equity. In the middle of the day it
becomes debt.
And by the end of the day it's back to
being equity again. See who can pull
that off.
You know how much money banks make
threading the needle trying to Because
each of these groups has different
definitions of debt.
And what banks do often is thread the
needle and convince each group that
they're getting exactly what they want.
So, I'll give you an example. It's
called trust preferred stock. And I'm
going to first describe what it looks
like. And then I want you to remember
the the distinction we drew between debt
and equity and tell me which bucket
you'd put it into.
And then I'll talk through what exactly
happened when it was created.
First, its birthplace is kind of
unclear. It's either born at Goldman
Sachs or one of the other investment
banks. The banker who created is kind of
passed on into posterity.
But here's what trust preferred stock
look like. It came with a fixed dividend
payment
that was set contractually up front.
That fixed dividend payment was tax
deductible. This banker managed to
convince the IRS that it was more like
interest than dividends. It was tax
deductible.
And if you failed to make the fixed
dividend payment, you didn't default,
but the holders of the trust preferred
got voting rights and essentially became
common stock.
Fixed dividend, tax deductible, loss of
control.
That looks an awful lot like
debt or equity?
That looks like debt to me.
And here was the final coup that the
banker pulled off. He got the ratings
agencies
to classify it as equity.
I ran into one of the people who sat on
that committee that classified as
equity. And I said, "What were you guys
even thinking?
Why would you treat this as equity?"
And he gave me two reasons. One stupid
and one incredibly stupid.
I'll give you the stupid reason first.
He said,
"It didn't come with a maturity date.
Debt usually comes with a finite
maturity. Equity doesn't."
And that kind of makes sense. Right?
Until you remember that Boeing issued
how many What was the maturity of those
bonds?
A 100-year bond. Right? Do any of you
buy a 100-year bond expecting to collect
the face value? I hope not because
you're being incredibly optimistic.
And once you've gone 100 years, why not
go 1,000 years or make those console
bonds? The The Canadian and the British
governments used to issue bonds which
did not come with a maturity date.
If I were advising Boeing, I'd say,
"Issue console bonds. You might have to
pay a slightly higher interest rate, but
the ratings agencies are going to treat
it as equity and keep giving increasing
your rating as you issue debt."
That was the stupid reason.
You know the incredibly stupid reason
was? He said it was called preferred
stock.
Come on, guys. You've opened a door for
me where I'm going to go on a renaming
convention where I'm going to take
everything on my balance sheet. Say
long-term debt, we don't call that debt
anymore. We'll call that long-term
preferred stock. You can't classify
something as debt or equity based on
what it's called.
But they classified it as equity. And
now you can see
why I mean this was an incredibly
profitable security for banks to get
companies to issue. Why? Because banks
Companies that couldn't afford to borrow
money could now issue preferred stock
to raise money and actually have their
rating go up while they were actually
borrowing money.
So, if you went to work for an
investment bank
in the early '90s, incredible pressure
on you
to convince every person who walked in
through the door that the right security
for them was trust preferred because you
got such a high fee on it.
So, let's say you can't beat that
pressure. You got to do what you were
hired to do.
But you want to do the least damage you
can while you're making a living.
You got to sell trust preferred.
And remember all the characteristics of
trust preferred. I want you to tell me
which
groups of firms will be less damaged by
issuing trust preferred or might not be
damaged at all. The right group to
target trust preferred at.
So, the first group of firms that are
under levered
and choose not to borrow money because
of a rating constraint. Remember we
talked about Those companies have a
single A A+. So, they're under levered.
They can afford to borrow more, but
they're choosing not to because they're
worried about the rating.
The second group of firms are over
levered.
But they could slip through this
loophole and issue more debt by issuing
preferred trust preferred. Which of
these two groups is the is is the
preferred group if your objective is not
to any damage? The under levered group
with the rating constraint
or the over levered group that can slip
through the loophole and issue the trust
preferred? Wait, what do you think?
And the under levered group, they have
excess debt capacity, which means they
have the cash flows. They can issue the
trust preferred. They can live They get
their cake and eat it, too. Right? The
rating stays okay, maybe even goes up.
The second group,
but see You know, what's the problem
with using a loophole and issuing the
trust preferred? You fooled the ratings
agency. Right?
But who have you not fooled?
I don't think there's something called
mother distress.
But there is a real distress factor
you're going to run into. Right? Which
is you're over levered, which means you
don't have the cash flows to service the
debt. And what have I done with your
trust preferred? I've added dividend
payments on top.
You're going to go bankrupt. The only
consolation prize is you're going to go
bankrupt with a really good rating.
I don't know what that does for you. You
know?
But it's amazing how companies and banks
thought this was a game. That this was a
game your objective was to fool the
ratings agency
by slipping through the cracks.
Banks play this game with regulatory
capital all the time.
I mean if I had my druthers and I were
writing the banking laws, I'd write
regulatory capital in terms of common
equity. If bank is short of regulatory
capital, it has to issue shares
because they allow you to go with what
what they call quasi equity. And that's
an opening that banks exploit to create
all kinds of strange instruments
that look like equity or called equity
but are really nothing to do with
equity.
This is not a game. Distress can destroy
a company. Your objective is not to fool
a rate I mean you got to factor in
ratings agencies, but you can't make
this all about can we fool the ratings
agencies?
Yes.
You'd be surprised at what how stupid
banks can get in this process as well,
how lazy they they often can be because
when everybody was lending to telecom,
it's true a big chunk of the debt came
from corporate bonds, but it's almost
like the banks didn't want to be left
out of the game. Cuz remember banks have
their own incentives to push up their
loan portfolios cuz they look good in
the good times, right? You get much more
income. So banks are not immune from
falling into that spell of everybody
else's lending to them, why shouldn't I
do it as well?
So let's see where we are. We've
designed the perfect debt. You got the
tax guys okay.
You've tried to keep these three groups
as happy as you can keep them. You can't
make they're all they they
obviously they won't all be delirious
but what you're doing, but at least
they're not so deeply disappointed that
they take it out on you.
The fourth step
is you want to check to see if bond
holders if you're issuing public bonds
whether bond holders will buy your
bonds. You're saying why wouldn't they?
For two reasons. One is perhaps you've
never issued bonds before, right? You're
a newbie and they said and so you have
no history.
The second is you have a history, but
it's a bad history.
Remember we talked about the Nabisco not
being Nabisco RJR Nabisco in 1987
doing a leveraged buyout and essentially
ripping off the bond holders.
Five years later Nabisco went back
public again and decided to issue bonds
again and nobody would buy their bonds.
And who could blame them, right? They
remembered '87 so why would we buy your
bonds?
So if you have no history or a bad
history
even if this is the right kind of debt
for you, bond holders might not be
willing in which case you got to pay
really high interest, right? To get them
to buy. So you might have to sugarcoat
the bonds. Make it acceptable.
In the late '80s the way this you know
one of the ways companies tried to
sugarcoat the bonds is they tried to
make the bonds rating sensitive. Merrill
Lynch invented these bonds where the
coupon rate on the bond would actually
change as the rating changed. It was
almost a direct consequence of the
Nabisco effect, right? Cuz in Nabisco
what happened was you bought these bonds
which were single A or double A rated
bonds and the company did a leveraged
buyout and made them double B rated
bonds and your coupon rate stayed fixed.
That's what damaged you so much. If your
coupon rate adjusted with the rating,
obviously as a bond buyer you're much
more willing to buy bonds saying, "Hey,
even if that happens, I'm okay."
Bonds are all you know especially in the
post-Nabisco started out an equity
component to them, a conversion option.
Why? Cuz if the equity investors are
ripping you off, you know what you can
do? Become one of them. In which case
who do they have to rip off? Conversion
options allowed you to do it. You're
sugarcoating the bond to make it
acceptable
to bond holders. You don't do it because
you want to. You don't do it to be nice.
You do it because if you if you didn't
do it, you wouldn't be able to issue the
bonds at a reasonable interest rate.
So when you see a bond issue with all
kinds of special features added on,
that's actually a signal that the
company is not in the best of shape with
the bond market and it's trying to make
its bonds acceptable.
So let's say you managed to do that as
well.
You got the perfect bond. You got the
tax okay. You made these three different
groups reasonably happy. You've
sugarcoated the bond.
You get ready to issue the bond. One
final stop you got to make.
You don't want to lock in market
mistakes that work against you.
You back up, right? You have a rating as
a company.
Is that rating the right rating? For
some companies it might be, but let's
say you as a company believe you're
being underrated. You know what I mean
by underrated, right? You should really
be single A, but the
ratings agency is giving you a triple B
rating. And let's say the right kind of
debt for you is a long-term fixed rate
bond.
You don't want to issue that long-term
rate bond today because
that bond will be priced as if you're a
triple B rated company and you believe
you deserve an A+ rating.
So what should you do? You might use
bridge financing. Bridge financing is
short-term financing and then during
that period what are you going you're
going to go to the ratings agency and
try to convince them that they want to
It might not work.
But the if you're underrated, you won't
you don't want to lock in that mistake
by going out and issuing long-term bonds
today.
What if you're overrated as a you know
Caleb you talked about an overrated
company. What are you going to be
tempted to do?
Issue as much as you can, right?
In fact, this is part of a more general
question. If you're overpriced as a
company in video when it 3.3 trillion
or your company and should you take
advantage of what you feel is a market
mistake?
And your first reaction is why shouldn't
I? It's not I who created the mistakes.
So my advice to companies if you need
the money, of course you got to go out
and borrow the money. But if you don't
need the money
my advice is don't try to take advantage
of market mistakes cuz you have a
long-term objective of staying in the
market. You don't want to be taking
advantage of a mistake for a couple of
hundred million dollars and then having
to pay for it in a future bond issue.
So you're underrated, you want to be
careful about kind of issuing long-term
debt and you might have to wait. If
you're overrated, I will leave it to
your conscience and your whatever your
sense of business ethics might be and
what you need to do, but you're going to
see the temptation to go out and raise
as much capital as you can
from equity if you're overpriced or from
debt
if you're overrated and that capital is
then going to sit on your balance sheet
and you'll be tempted to do stupid
things with it. So there are all kinds
of things that emerge from that. So
that's the entire process.
You know don't get let the this is just
a previous five pages pulled together in
one. It essentially goes through the
process.
I don't see why you need a banker
advising you on debt. I think the
company should be in the best position
to design debt for them.
You're saying what if I come up with a
kind of bond that nobody will buy? That
might require a bank, that deal making
part, right?
But your objective is to try to get debt
that looks like your company so that in
good times you have lots of cash flows
service the debt in bad times as your
cash flows drop off, your debt cash
flows also decrease so you're not in
trouble.
So the next part of the process of
the practical ways in which you can
convert this framework to designing the
right debt.
So I'm going to go through three
different ways in which you can design
the debt. The first one to me is
actually the one that I stick with
because it's the most general, it's the
one that I'd like you to apply for your
companies. The other two are more
quantitative. They So if those of you
are numbers oriented want something more
specific might like the other two, but
they're much more difficult to actually
work with in practice.
The first one is to break down a company
into its businesses
and look at what kind of debt is right
for each business.
The case of Coca-Cola and Boeing, they
were in single business, it was easy.
But in the case of Disney, remember then
the theme park business, the movie
business, the broadcasting business, now
in the streaming business very different
business in terms of cash flows and
currencies.
You might want to design the right debt.
I call this intuitive. You tell me what
your company does, what a typical
project looks like and I'll tell you
what the right kind of debt for that
company is.
The second approach
is project financing. And this is
especially useful for companies that
actually borrow against projects rather
than borrow as a company and fund
projects. Big infrastructure companies
often will take each project, borrow
against the project. There we're going
to go back and use the same cash flows
we used to come up with the net present
value to actually derive what the right
kind of debt for a company is.
And the third approach
is to look at how macro variables affect
your company. When interest rates go up,
what happens to your cash flows? If
inflation goes up, so essentially it's a
very data-driven approach for saying
let's see what drives your cash flows
and let's design debt based on what we
find.
So let's start with the intuitive
way of designing debt. I'm going to
start with Disney.
I broke it down into five business.
Exactly same five business I did the
bottom up beta.
So with each business I'm going to stop
and ask what's a typical project look
like for Disney?
And what's the right kind of debt given
that project?
The advantage for Disney is because it's
a multi-business company, it can it has
more flex in the process, right? In one
one business can make up for another.
But let's say take each one. So let's
start with the movie business. Typical
project is usually short-term. I know
some movies take forever to make.
But typical project is short-term.
And for for Disney at least in terms of
the the cash outflows tend to be in US
dollars. They pay their actors in
dollars. Often they're you know they
shoot the movie in dollars.
Unless they make some of the animation
in India and then you might have some of
the
And depending on the Disney movie, the
inflows can be either global or more US
based. When they make action movies, the
Avengers movies, the revenues are very
global.
Asia is a big contributor. When they
make their animated or the Pixar movies,
they tend to be more US-centric.
China, for instance, not interested in
Pixar movies at all. They get very
little revenues.
So, you tell me where your movies make
their revenues, I can start to So, it
should be probably short-term debt.
Probably dollar debt because your
outflows are in dollars.
But, movie success is measured by gate
receipts, right?
Wouldn't it be neat if you could tie the
coupon rate on the bond to how well the
movie does?
Less of an issue with Disney, which
makes dozens of movies, but you take a
company like
a movie company like Lionsgate, which
makes one or two movies,
you might want to design your debt in
such a way that if the movie does really
well, gate receipts exceed exceed a half
a billion, you're willing to pay 15% and
the gate receipts drop through the
floor,
you'd like the coupon rate to drop.
You're saying, "Who'd buy a bond like
that?"
Disney actually issued Little Mermaid
bonds.
Where you And people actually bought it,
right? Partly because they wanted to get
the the certificate and hang it up in
their basement room. It's I lent money
to make the Little Mermaid and tell
their grandchildren, "Look, I was the
one who funded the movie." You know?
But, one of the most fascinating bonds
ever issued were Bowie bonds. Have you
heard of Bowie bonds?
Huh?
Do you Do you remember how the bonds
were constructed?
And why did he have to do that, right?
Usually, they get paid by studios, so
something must have triggered this,
right?
He actually ended up with the with a in
a conflict with his with his music
companies. He bought back the rights to
all of his music, which left him with a
cash flow problem. Rockstar cash flow
problem don't go together, right? Seven
Rolls-Royces, how do you maintain them?
So, he approached a banker in New York
and I again, I don't know his name. You
could probably find it you know, doing a
Google search. And the banker designed
these bonds that were going to be you
know, backed up by the music.
But, what made the bonds unique was the
coupon rate on the bond was tied to how
many These were the days when you
actually sold records. If the records
went platinum, the coupon rate be 12% so
or one day we woke up and said, "David
Bowie's strange-looking hair, I'm never
buying music from this guy again." The
coupon rate actually dropped to 0%.
If people will buy Bowie bonds,
why not Little Mermaid bonds?
Right? The bond market would be a lot
more fun if you had running against Kim
Kardashian bonds and LeBron James bonds
and Steven Smith So, basically, all
these So, you're backing it up with cash
flows.
There's a swimming pool company in the
Northeast that actually issued bonds
where they tied the coupon rate to the
temperature, the average summer
temperature in the Northeast.
You can see why, right?
Summer temperature's high, you so you
know, you sell your revenues are high.
But, if there's a particularly cool
summer, they didn't sell very much.
There was an Italian soccer team that
tied its bond coupon rate. They were
actually in division two, whether they
made it back to division one or stayed
in division two.
People will buy all kinds of stuff.
Why? Because they think they're experts
on things they're not experts about.
But, here's my favorite example. Say
you're an insurance company.
Right?
Most of the years, you collect premiums,
you pay out, you know, you pay out the
Most of the time, you make money unless
you have what?
A catastrophe, a hurricane,
that LA fire.
Wouldn't it be neat if you're an
insurance company and you borrowed money
that in the event of a catastrophe,
you'd still be okay?
Design a bond from scratch.
Leon, help me out. If I wanted to design
a bond as an insurance company to
protect me in the event of a
catastrophe,
I'm your lawyer, so tell me what you
want me to put in as clauses to protect
you.
First step, you'd have to define the
catastrophe, right? So, can't just be if
there's an earthquake, an earthquake
that exceeds eight on the Richter scale.
Let's pick a high enough number.
And what what do you want to be able to
do as an insurance company?
If if that big catastrophe happens, you
want to
cut back on interest payments, maybe
suspend interest payments for 3 years,
reduce your principal payment by 50%.
You think,
"Why would people buy this bond?"
Because the interest rate will be really
high. It's again, you're not pulling a
fast one. These are called catastrophe
bonds. They actually exist. Small
insurance companies use them.
And the coupon and the principal on the
bond is tied to a specific catastrophe.
So, if you're East Coast-based, it might
be a hurricane. West Coast-based might
be an earthquake or a fire.
And increasingly, I think you're going
to see that with insurance companies
because it turned out that one point in
time, big insurance companies like
Allstate or State Farm said, "We don't
need to do that."
Cuz we're
But, if you look at the LA fires,
insurance companies that are exposed
there, even the large ones are looking
at potential payouts that are so large
that could tip them over.
The cat bonds basically are trying to
bring that in.
So, that's the movie business. Let's
move on to the broadcasting business.
Typically, again, short-term and but you
could go multiple seasons and your
success is measured with ratings, right?
You don't want to issue rating-sensitive
bonds, but the ratings are not the
ratings that you get from Moody's and
S&P. It's the ratings that Nielsen
measures. At least with traditional TV,
that used to be the objective.
With streaming, all bets are off.
I wouldn't even know how to design debt
for a streaming project because it's
very difficult to trace out the effects
on the cash flows because it might be
more subscribers, higher lower churn
rates. Maybe you can tie the coupon rate
to the churn rate, right? See if you
But, you're going to see some really
creative ways in which these streaming
companies borrow money because you want
to tie again how well you you know, how
well you did to how much you pay out.
The theme park business should be the
most real estate-focused
of Disney's many businesses, right?
Long-term, big infrastructure
investments. And the cash flows will
depend on where you're building the
theme park. If you're building them in,
you know, and even there, you know, even
though you might build them in the US in
Anaheim or in Orlando, you're drawing
customers from all over. So, if you
could design your debt in a way that
reflects that,
you made yourself less risky.
By now, you see the theme. You look at
what your cash flows are driven by,
you're trying to design the debt.
The consumer products and the
interactive, you can talk about at least
at that time, interactive was their
growth business. If you had a business
which it should be issuing convertible
debt, this would be the business to do
it.
Today, of course, interactive is gone.
Streaming has taken its place.
Start thinking about if Netflix were to
issue debt,
what form should it take? It should
probably be tied to
the number of subscribers, right? And if
it's content commitments, that's exactly
what you do. That's why leases are such
a great way for retailers to borrow
because it ties it to specific stores.
If the store doesn't do well, you
abandon the lease and the debt goes away
with the store.
There's a reason particular kinds of
borrowing evolve in businesses. It It
gives you a way to match up your debt to
your assets.
So, I would like you to think of your
company and start thinking about what a
typical project looks like for your
multiple businesses in each business.
And this to me is the creative part of
debt design because you're saying, "What
if I design a bond that has never been
seen before?" Odds are you won't be able
to issue that bond because it's
But, let's say you this was you did this
for a living and you ran into this for
five companies. You said, "I wish I had
that kind of bond." After the fifth
company, this might be your chance to
create a type of bond.
Do you think Lou Ranieri actually you
know, sat down and said, "I'd like to
think about real estate-based" He He
basically ran into this constraint of I
have mortgage you know, I have all these
mortgages as assets. How come there
isn't a debt that is tied directly to
mortgages?
He created mortgage-backed financing
because he ran into enough cases where
he said that would help.
And I think we're at a point where you
could be thinking about macro risks and
ways of bringing them into debt.
And I'll let you think about the macro
risks that are floating around.
Maybe debt that is you know, some kind
of a tariff component to it because if
that is what's going to tip you over the
edge, putting in And again, you're not
doing it to rip off the bondholders.
They're They're getting a fair bond, but
they think they're better at forecasting
things than the rest of the market is
and this is what they want to make their
bet on.
So, at least focus on duration,
currency, fixed or floating. So, each of
the duration is going to be based on you
know, whether your projects are
long-term or short-term. Currency is
going to be based on what currency your
cash flows are in. Fixed or floating
rate is going to be based on how much
pricing power you have. You're saying,
"How would I know that?" Take a look at
your company, right? If it's a brand
name company, it probably has got a lot
of pricing power it can pass it through.
But, if you're in a business that's
intensely competitive, where it's
difficult to push through price changes
on your own,
then you should be issuing floating rate
debt. And finally, straight or
convertible will depend on whether
you're a mature company with a
relatively low growth in the future, the
Costcos, the Walmarts of the world, the
Home Depots,
or whether you're a growth company, a
company like Palantir where all of your
value is going to come from future
growth.
In fact, Palantir would be a fascinating
company to design debt in
because you could tie it to the size of
the defense contract and essentially
look at, "Hey, if that is what's driving
my cash flows, I should be trying to
bring it in to the group into the bond."
That's the first way to design debt and
to me that's going to be the central way
in which you're going to design debt.
There's a second way you can design debt
and this is particularly useful if you
want to borrow money against a specific
project.
Of all of Disney's businesses, the theme
park business is probably the one that's
best suited to borrowing money on its
own. So, bankers are lending money
against a big infrastructure real estate
project. You want to borrow money, it's
going to be project specific.
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to go back to the cash flows I
used to get the net present value of the
project. So, this is from way back in
time, session 8, 9, 10.
There I used it to get the net present
value, but here I'm going to use it for
something a little different. So, there
are my cash flows each year. There's a
big upfront investment. There's my
terminal value. The way we compute
present values we discount them back at
the cost of capital. So, then there's my
$3.3 billion net present value that we
got last
I'm going to take each present value and
then I'm going to multiply by the year I
get it. In a minute I'll I'll explain
what I'm doing when I do this. So, in
the last column I take the present value
multiply by the year. So, minus 922 * 1,
minus 730 * 2.
It's a present value times when you get
it. You add up the last column, you get
62,355.
Think, "What the heck are you doing?" If
I divide the 62,355 by 3.3 billion,
I've effectively what's called the
Macaulay duration. In a typical bond,
this is how you compute the duration.
You take the cash flow, you take the
present value
I've computed the duration of this
project to be roughly 19 years
based on the cash flows.
How's that going to help me? If I'm
going to go out and borrow money on this
project, I want the duration of the debt
that I issue to be roughly 19 years.
Duration, not the maturity, right?
Duration would mean either issue zero
coupon bond with a 19-year
maturity or if it's a regular coupon
bond, maybe a 25-year or 30-year bond
because remember when there's a coupon,
the duration is going to be lower than
the maturity.
Yes.
T is this whichever year you get the
cash flow in.
So, basically it'll be 2 * -7, so it
should be just that times that will
always give me the last column. So, it's
in fact how we compute the Macaulay
duration of a traditional coupon bond.
I've just stolen that idea and applied
it to a typical project and computed the
duration of the project, right?
And here of course the currency is you
can it's a real project, so you can then
say, "I want to put debt that's about 19
years in duration
is mostly in Latin American currencies
because it's a project in real."
Does Disney have pricing power?
I think so. I mean, I see the prices
that people have to pay to get into a
theme park. You know, they're not
exactly lagging inflation.
So, if they want to issue floating rate
debt, I would encourage them. So, we
the bulk of debt designers are right
there, right? 19-year duration
in in Latin American currencies, perhaps
the real,
and then finally to top it all off, you
know, if you can make it floating rate
debt, go for it. And if you cannot do
that,
then you can issue debt in dollars and
then try to do use swaps or derivatives
to get rid of that mismatch. But your
end game should be after I'm done with
all of this, I don't want to be exposed
to this extra risk because I've used
dollar debt to fund, you know, a Latin
American project. Yes.
Not a project,
company.
Yeah.
A company is just a portfolio of
projects, right? So, it's really choice
between whether you're borrowing against
a project or a portfolio of projects.
Caleb's question was about a single
project and there again I drew to a
portfolio. So, think of a company as a
portfolio of projects, right?
Mhm.
The books show the project is probably
going to be finite, right? You're not
going to get the terminal value. So,
long-term projects obviously will have
that much bigger amount in year 10, but
if you have salvage value instead of
terminal value, I mean, if you remember
the Celsius project, when you put the
salvage value in, the duration shrunk.
So, the Celsius project, if I were
planning to run it as a 15-year project,
I would have funded it with much more
short-term debt than if I ran it as a
perpetual life, a longer life. So, your
choice about how to run a project is
also going to determine what kind of
debt to use for that project.
So, the perfect theme park debt should
be Latin American currencies, roughly 19
years in duration, and if possible, I
would like to tie the coupon payments to
how many people come to the theme park.
So, if the theme park is a complete
bust,
my coupon rate drops. Less of an issue
for Disney
than for Six Flags, right? Because
Disney has all these other businesses
protecting it. Six Flags, you know,
you're
In fact, Six Flags probably in hindsight
wished it had issued all its debt as
debt tied to the number of people
because it's a company that's hopelessly
over-levered and can't figure out a way
to back out of that corner.
But the more single business you become,
the more you worry about mismatching
your debt because it could take you
down.
Which brings us to the third way in
which you can design debt. And I'm at
least going to get started on this
process because it's very data-driven,
right?
So, third way what I'm going to look at
is how my company has done
over time as a function of macroeconomic
variables out there. As interest rates
change, as inflation changes, because
the data is going to tell you whether
your company is cyclical or not. The
data is going to tell you how your
company does when the dollar gets
stronger.
And there are two dimensions on which I
can look at my company. I can look at
operating cash flows.
Why? I want to see how much my income
goes up and down.
But I can also look at the value of my
firm, which captures the present value
of So, I'm measuring two different
aspects of my firm, my year-to-year
earnings and the value of my company.
So, with Disney here's what I did. I
went back to 1985.
I got the operating income every year.
So, that comes right out of the income
statement. If you have Capital IQ, you
can download the data. I also downloaded
the enterprise value. Remember the
enterprise value is market value of
equity plus debt minus cash, the market
value of the operating assets. Risk of
stating the obvious, you can see
earnings go up for the for the most
part, but they have good years and bad
years and percentage changes are going
to capture that. Same thing with the
enterprise value.
So, percentage change in operating
income and percentage change in firm
value every single year. So, that's my
starting point. Start with the company,
look at how your company's done over
time.
And I brought in
in terms of macroeconomic variables,
three macro macroeconomic variables and
I'll talk about why each one matters.
The first I'm sorry, four economic
macroeconomic variables. First is I
looked at the T-bond rate and how much
it changed on a year-to-year basis.
I wanted to see how sensitive my company
was to changes in long-term interest
rates.
Second column, I looked at the
percentage change in real GDP.
I'll actually send you a link to this
Federal Reserve site called FRED. Have
any of you used FRED? It's an amazing
site. It's the most amazing
macroeconomic data site I've ever used
anywhere in the world. And it's free.
That's the best part of it, right?
So, you can download pretty much
everything from exchange rates going
back 50 years to GDP, interest rates,
stable rates, whatever you wanted to do
going back in time. So, that's my source
for all of these. So, that's a
percentage change in the 10-year T-bond
rate. So, I want to be specific or the
T-note rate if you prefer to call it by
its right name.
The second is a percentage change in
real GDP every year. What does that
capture? It captures how the real
economy is doing. When that number is
negative, you have a recession.
That number is positive, you're growing
and the larger the number, the more
you're growing.
The third column I looked at percentage
change in the CPI. That captures the
inflation rate change. Notice I'm
looking at changes in each of these
variables rather than levels because I
want to see the changes in my company as
those numbers change. And the last
column, I have the percentage change in
the US dollar. You're saying against
what currency?
There's actually a weighted US dollar on
FRED which captures how the dollar moves
against
um
the other currencies put together. So,
when the dollar gets stronger as a
whole, that number goes up and
So, rather than track individual
currencies, I've kind of created So,
these four variables are the variables I
picked. But if you're doing an oil
company, there would be a fifth column
there, right? What did you look at? You
look at the oil price every year. So, be
creative because the variable the data
is there. You're trying to ask, "How
does my company do as these external
factors move?"
So, here's the first thing I'm going to
do. I'm going to look at how sensitive
my company is
to changes in long-term rates.
I'm going to look at both operating
income and firm value. I'm going to
argue that those when I look at that
that relationship, I'm going to get a
sense of the duration of my company's
assets. Sounds weird that looking at
interest rates going to do it, but I'm
going to make that link. So, I'm going
to start by looking at how my operating
income changes as interest rates change,
and then I'm going to look at how much
firm value changes as interest rates
change. So, here's my first No, first
regression. I took the change in
Disney's firm value on a year-by-year
basis
and ran a regression against changes in
interest rates on a year-by-year basis.
I don't want to get too excited. The
R-squared is terrible. The T statistic
is close to zero. So, again, this is not
something I want to take to an analyst
and say this is but to the extent that
you run this regression, I'm going to
argue that this coefficient that you see
on the change in interest rates, minus
2.32,
is actually a measure of the duration of
Disney's assets. It sound like a leap of
faith, right? You're saying, why would
running a regression of changes in firm
value against changes in interest rates
give you a measure of duration?
I want to take back take you back to
foundations. You talked about duration
in foundations, right?
What is the duration of a bond? There
are multiple definitions. Give me, you
know, one or two. What are the some of
the definite What's the duration What is
the duration of a bond measure?
Yes.
One is it's a weighted average of when
you get the cash flows, right? So, if
you have a high coupon If you have a
zero coupon bond, the duration and the
maturity match up. It's 8 years. So, one
way we think about duration is in years,
number of years, right? What's the other
way to think about duration?
Why do we care about it? Kelly?
What does it measure?
It's a measure of how much your bond
price will change for a 1% So, it's
actually like a calculus. It's the the
it's the first derivative of the bond
price to changes in interest rates. For
every 1% increase in interest rates, how
much does my bond price drop? So, it's
going to be a negative coefficient,
right? So, bond interest rates go up,
bond So, duration also measures how
sensitive your bond price is going to be
to changes in interest rates.
Do you see the starting of a link? What
is the regression coefficient measuring?
It measures how sensitive my firm value
is to changes in interest rates. That's
exactly what duration on a bond
measures.
You're saying, why didn't we do duration
the traditional way? Because I don't
have cash flows in the company for the
next 10 years and a face value. So, it's
a kind of a shortcut. So, if you think
about duration, the duration of a bond
is basically a measure of how sensitive
a bond price is to changes in interest
rates. And I'm going to argue that my
regression coefficient serves exactly
the same purpose. It tells me how
sensitive. So, if I have a
a company with really long-term assets,
it should be much more sensitive to
changes in interest rates in terms of
dropping in value than a company with
short-term assets. A Boeing should be
much more exposed to changes in
long-term rates than a Dell should be
because much more short-term, right?
So, that's basically why. So, if you
think about duration as a percentage
change in value, the traditional
duration measures, which is what we use
for bonds, we use the coupon and the
face value and we back into duration. We
can't do that with a company. So, that's
why instead we're running a regression,
taking the coefficient of the
regression, and using it as a measure of
duration. But,
I need to be open about the limitations
of the approach. First is it needs past
data.
If you try to do this for a Palantir or
a DoorDash,
probably going to run is you're not
going to get 50 years of data like I did
for Disney. You might get five, six
years of data, and it's going to be very
noisy data. Second, when you run a
regression and you get a coefficient,
remember from the beta regressions, it
comes with the T statistic and a and a
standard error. So, it's going to be
noisy, and we'll talk about what to do
about it.
But, it's just a different way of
thinking about duration for a company
than duration for debt by running this
regression.
I also ran a regression of operating
income against interest rates. Here, I
just wanted to see was my operating
income go up or down as interest rates
go up. And every 1% increase in
long-term rates reduces my operating
income by 7.2%.
Remember T-bond rates in 2021
were 1.5%. T-bond rates today are 4 and
1/2% and rising. They briefly got close
to 5% towards the end of last week.
If you can take this regression through,
that's not good news for Disney's
operating income. Historically, its
operating income has been hurt every
time long-term rate For lots of
different reasons. Might be some
intermediate step that's not even been
captured, but it's not good. Are there
companies which might actually benefit
from having higher long-term rates? What
kinds of business you think will
generate higher operating income with
higher long-term rates?
Bank Usually, it's financial service
companies are the ones that you point to
because they can reorient their assets
as long as they're not locked in, right?
So, the argument is service companies
can benefit because they can pass the
interest rate through.
But, even there you got to be careful
that you don't have too many things.
Remember, you know,
if you go back a couple of years, a lot
of banks were exposed because there are
all these securities that they bought
with low coupon rates, and then the
interest rate went up.
So, duration here captures how
sensitive.
My second stop is I'm going to look at
how sensitive my company is
to changes in real GDP.
Remember talked about cyclical,
non-cyclical, and usually we have this
thing of, you know,
auto companies are cyclical,
but discount retailers are not.
We don't know whether that's true,
right? It's a completely empirical
question. And here's the easiest way to
see if your company is cyclical. If you
run a regression of your company's
income and value against real GDP,
if your company is cyclical, you should
see a big negative coefficient. Do you
see why? When the economy is doing well,
I'm sorry. Big positive coefficient. The
economy is doing well, you should expect
to make more money, be worth more if the
economy is doing
If you're not cyclical, the coefficient
should be close to zero.
And if you're countercyclical, and there
are a few businesses that are claimed to
be countercyclical, you should get a
negative coefficient. Again, before I
run the regression, I want to get that
lined up. So, when I look at the
regression, here's what I see for
Disney.
A plus 6.7 for change in firm value, and
a plus 6.64 for change in operating
income. What does it tell me? At least
based on this historical data, it looks
like Disney
is a cyclical company, but and the
coefficients are statistically
significant. So, it does look like
having a stronger economy does help
Disney as a company. You're saying,
that's obvious. Might as well get the
data lined up. It does look
If you took Con Ed and ran this
regression, you get a coefficient close
to zero. Con Ed seems to be unaffected
because it's a regulated utility, but
whether the economy is booming or it's
in or it's going into recession.
So, we're running the regression against
real GDP to get a sense of is my company
cyclical.
Third, I wanted to see how Disney does
when the dollar gets stronger or weaker.
Okay?
I want you to think about as Disney,
what a strong Where What businesses a
stronger dollar would help them on, and
what businesses it would hurt them on.
Let's see what the collective So, if you
look at the theme park business, is it
helped or hurt by a stronger dollar?
The US theme parks are definitely going
to be hurt, right? Because people fly in
and they have to pay higher prices. So,
a stronger dollar to US theme parks.
It's tougher to make the call on the
Shanghai or the Tokyo. Uh but in
general, a stronger dollar is not good
for Disney in the theme park business.
In fact, I would argue if you go down
the path, the net effect of a stronger
dollar is probably going to be negative.
At least that's what my priors would
lead me to believe.
But, we have the data. Let's see what
the data shows us.
It actually turns out that the firm
value is almost unaffected by
Look at the T statistic, 0.67. Remember
the cutoff for that is two. So,
basically, it doesn't look like a
stronger dollar helped. Collectively as
a company, it looks like Disney is
unaffected by whether the dollar gets
stronger or weaker. And if you look at
operating income, a stronger dollar it
does push down their operating income.
And there's a there's a puzzle here,
right? You're saying, if my earnings
drop when I have a stronger dollar, how
come my firm value doesn't? Because my
firm value The firm value has other
things that go into it, the growth rate,
the cost of capital. So, all those
effects might end up evening out. So,
the bottom line here is Disney's
operating
have a final interview with I have
If you're on Zoom, can you can you mute
yourself, please?
I think that's somebody on Zoom. So, the
operating income here is clearly
affected by the dollar, but the firm
value is not.
Last piece, and then we'll wrap this up.
So, I looked to see whether Disney's
firm value And what am I doing when I
when I look at inflation, what am I
trying to measure?
Pricing power, right? If you have
pricing power, your earnings should go
up as inflation goes up. And if you're
able to pass it through, your firm value
shouldn't be hurt by inflation because
your earnings go up, your discount rate
goes up. And with Disney, that's exactly
what we find. Change in inflation rate
pushes up my operating income. So, they
pass it through to their customers,
but it has almost no effect on value.
So, again, the objective here is you're
trying to get a sense of what does my
company do as these macroeconomic
variables shift.
The bottom line is we bring them all
together. Here's what the regressions
lead me to believe about Disney. That
collectively, if I believe the
regression, and I'm going to put a
qualifier there because the T statistic
was so close to zero,
the duration of the asset is 2.33 years.
It is increasingly cyclical.
It is hurt by a stronger dollar and it
tends to move with inflation.
All that would lead me to design debt
for Disney that matches up to what I
found from the regressions. So, I'm
going to stop there. I will send you the
link to this macro because I've updated
it on an annual basis. All you have to
do is enter your numbers and see what
you get. I'll also tell you because it's
a small data sample, you're going to get
strange-looking results and terrible T
statistics. Next class, we'll talk about
what to do about those. So, I'll see you
on Wednesday.